cada vez que me invitan a eventos como
este vengo gustoso me han invitado a
muchas ocasiones y cada vez que voy voy
con ganas de aprender y voy con mucho
mucho gusto si no invítame voluntarioso
permita do también hacer nuestras
ceremonias y diferentes tipos de eventos
principalmente familiares o de la
empresa o de caridad y voy también con
mucho mucho mucho gusto pero es plática
un par de ocasiones donde invitaron a
ser maestro de ceremonias en eventos
oficiales y ese dije yo no lo vuelvo a
hacer como tienes aquí a todos los
funcionarios y tienes que presentar a
cada uno de ellos el señor licenciado
juan manuel treviño de la garza ibarra
coordinador de esto y esto y licenciada
margarita treviño la garza y para que la
hermana del otro también coordinadora de
esto y estoy esto y toda esa atención de
esa formalidad y hoy está muy incómodo y
de repente uno eso me olvido no dije
licenciada y que el señor tal en cuanto
vi una oportunidad sus asistentes unión
conmigo me creo que te pasó en el hit en
es licenciado que me va a correr
o sea oyendo me cuenta una disculpa pero
banderas tan importantes y es muy
importante para correr está enojado mi
jefe y es que pero por qué es tan
importante y eso me dejó pensando y
pensando y pensando es que por qué es
tan importante que te lleguen
licenciados no tengo ningún problema con
sentir orgullo por estudiar una carrera
para nada no pero que exige hacer que te
ofenda que no te presenten
y dijo ese es el problema porque porque
llegamos a ese punto y empecé a pensar y
es común es parte de nuestra cultura
ustedes nos ha pasado muchas veces que
te presentan alguien te dice te presento
a mi compadre aquí el licenciado juan
manuel treviño la garza ibarra hermano
también nosotros
una familia muy grande y represento acá
al ingeniero tal y decir que todo siendo
licenciado a cara de kane en estudiarlo
no es problema pero el que lo empieces a
exigirnos empieza a llevar ya sea un
caminito de la arrogancia ese es mi
problema y es lo que me gusta que
empezamos a pensar porque puedes empezar
a acercar a la arrogancia empieza a
perder esa humildad una vez un chico
tuvo un problema en la empresa me
acerqué con él dijo qué es lo que pasa
en mi hijo mira yo soy ingeniero y
merezco respeto dije nada cree en cosas
si no fueras ingeniero no merecería ese
respeto
merece respeto porque es parte del
equipo porque es una persona respetable
nos estamos acercando hacia la
arrogancia a sentir que porque tenemos
un título universitario que tenemos un
puesto puesto su profesor sobre gerente
ya somos mejores personas y merecemos
más ese es el problema que yo tengo y al
perder esa humildad que es tan
importante estamos perdiendo también la
oportunidad de innovar de preguntar a
nuestro equipo de tener esas ideas
estamos cayendo en el octavo desperdicio
que es no utilizar la creatividad y el
talento de los miembros del equipo así
de sencillo simplemente preguntar todo
lo tiene que hacer es preguntar yo vas a
tener ahí muchas muchas muchas ideas y
por caer en la arrogancia perdemos esa
oportunidad tremenda y en mi padre
trabajó en una caseta como ésta en los
cines durante más de 40 años a mí me
encantaba ir de niño primero porque
había las películas gratis y después
presentaba a un lado las máquinas tengo
bien presente el sonido de los carretes
dando vuelta a la necesitas todo oscuro
si todo místico muy padre y mira por el
cuadrito la película y cuando fallaba
hacían caros no ven tan palomita ciudad
yo la que paga
o sea que para la gente a quien saludan
cuando llegue a una edad ya podían tener
un poquito más no me decía mira así
funcionan las márgenes por esto y
después me decía me diste mejora pues
esta pole aquí el carrete pastel aplicó
la cosa por la proyección se van a esta
pelea y esta pole porque se combina sola
y mejor mucho tiempo
y después regresaba a ese agua y las
poleas estas que pusieron a las quitaron
aquí no les importa la quitaron no les
importa kilos de fe les digo y ni
discusiones y decían qué desperdicio que
desperdicio y eso van quedando sus ideas
junto con sus ganas de querer hacer
hacer más y más y más y más ese retiro
ya hace muchos años y yo sigo pensando
que por más de 40 años esa empresa tuvo
las manos de mi padre cuando pudo haber
tenido también su cerebro por el mismo
precio cuántas ideas pero el generado se
dice que tenemos que preguntarle qué
opinas que podemos hacer ni siquiera ni
tan preguntarle que están implementando
por sí mismo las ideas pues solamente
tienes que decirle gracias muy bien yo
soy va a generar y si te gustaba puedo
informar del formato más pero nadie lo
escuchó nadie nunca le dijo gracias a un
simple gracias pudiera generar algo tan
grande viajes más y más y más mejoras
por esa empresa pero no se hizo en
simple gracias y lo hace de la manera
correcta
puedes energizar a la persona y puede
generar muchísimas cosas en alguna
ocasión nosotros contratamos un grupo de
estudiantes muchachos de 21 22 años de
universidad para que desarrollar un
proyecto en la empresa y aún no que le
dimos más madera del líder lo pusimos a
liderar el equipo al final del proyecto
me invitaron a la presentación de cierre
y vi los resultados estaban excedieron
expectativas pero
como el líder desarrollo del proyecto
como un líder o el grupo como las signo
tareas y al final estuvo reconociendo
cada uno de ellos por su contribución
individual eso me encantó terminé los
felicito a todos me fui con el líder al
hijo jett y meses talento natural
significa tenían la carrera ya lo traes
ahí estás liderando a la manera correcta
basada más cosas correctas sigue
desarrollando en llegar más lejos a mi
oficina y cuando llegué sentí que pude
verle y yo más sentí que debía haberle
dicho más así que sí mandarle un
correcto y después otra vez hoy en
verdad tienes esto seguirá muy lejos
ojalá que yo te voy a ayudar te atan al
hilo van en dos minutos más del correo
al tiempo después me enteré que cuando
recibí un correo de parte del director
del departamento alero estudiante éstos
recibirán una carta ese tipo del
director se emociona se la mandó a su
hermano mayor que trabaja en otra
empresa
telerman orgulloso del hermanito toma
esa carta la imprime salga su mamá su
mamá imagen se como el centro mamá
cuando es un niño que está en la escuela
que no termina está buscando una
oportunidad la empresa como esa y el
director le mandó una carta a imágenes
de nivel de orgullo norma fue la persona
refrigerador bom
en esta cultura cuando es una casa vas a
la cocina en todo el mundo que entre
aquí va a haber esa carta que le mandó
el director a mi hijo un chamaquito que
todo está estudiando y él me dice que
llegó vio la carta y se sintió muy padre
yo me gusta pensar como como estaba ese
ambiente como se sentía el orgullo la
energía en esta casa cuando llegaron
todos a comer estado sin la carta y un
lado y todo chiviado y los otros pastos
orgullosos que pagaron en mi cartita y
no algo tan grande tan hermoso que pasó
en esa casa esa vez inicio con algo muy
pequeño con dos minutos míos diciendo
con felicidades muchas gracias
así sencillo un gracias así tan sencillo
de un amigo que me dijo hoy en las
encuestas hay un equipo me salió que
tengo que agradecer más que tengo que
reconocer más cómo le hago que me
recomiendas más tú que es tan bueno para
eso que es tan inteligente tan guapo
él me dijo que yo no solamente les
comparto la experiencia
y que hoy gracias no debería hacer eso
perdón dependiendo de si es que no me
nace no no tengo no lo tengo unos genes
de ok ok no una parte lo que te da la
naturaleza pero otra parte la ex a tus
pies a practicarlo con que empiezas un
día de llegas gracias gracias nada más
protestas y gracias a sí ya se siente y
empieza a practicar y te va a salir
natural tracción natural y después ya
vas a decir más no esperes a tener un
discurso muy grande nada más con que
diga gracias eso para energizar a las
personas así es sencillo se dice que
somos un porcentaje lo que nos da la
naturaleza y otro porcentaje lo que no
estamos nutriendo desde pequeños
entonces y ya te diste cuenta que es
importante empieza nutrirte a mí me
gusta pensar que somos cincuenta y
cincuenta que podemos encontrar ese
balance y si tú dices yo ya ni cien ojos
porque me pare no joven y yo saliente
pues soy muy enojón y de ahí no me sacas
no pero te tienes otro porcentaje si tú
sabes la importancia del autocontrol de
la inteligencia emocional empieza a
desarrollar esa habilidad y vas a
controlar tu tú no cómo se controlan
esas emociones si se puede claro que se
puede y más sin desde chiquito empezamos
a nutrirlo y no ponga pretexto que no te
deum tú mismo empieza a desarrollar este
mismo si se puede y un intento mucho con
mi hija les presento mi princesa es la
mayor de mis tres hijos
le digo 32 un día mi esposo me dijo nos
aventamos el tercero pero el tercer hijo
yo me confundí
qué bueno que lo entendieron felices
felices con los tres niños
llega mi princesa un día en el kinder
llegan al kinder me dice papi me
encontré un lápiz hoy bien bonito en
lápiz así princesas y que mirar la
rosita tenía unos ponis con unos
unicornios aquí muy padre tenemos cuerda
y brillaban super para el lápiz y se lo
entrega la maestra para que salga la
dueña y la niñera fulanita estaba bien
contenta porque no lo encontraba y le
dije allí me aplaudieron todos porque
fui honesta y meike que sentiste cuando
te aplaudieron ahí muy padres y te gustó
el lápiz me encantó para pimentón y aún
así se lo viste la mente así porque eso
es hacer lo correcto y que sentiste
cuando un contraste sólo existe me gustó
lo que está tratando de tratar de nutrir
esa parte que que disfrute lo hacer lo
correcto tanto el reconocimiento sino
que lo haga porque disfrutan hacer lo
correcto eso es lo que estás buscando
con ella y con nosotros dos también como
supuesto y no todo es color de rosa con
el mismo tiempo también el kinder y
algún día me dijo papi ya te creo cuando
me dices que soy bonita
así es que me dijo que estaba enamorada
esto cada vez cada vez más
así cuando se enamora de ti porque eres
bonita y tu padre porque hice lo que
cualquier otro para haber hecho este
niño ya no está en esa escuela
no siento no tanto pero sí lo estuvo con
nosotros chica no fui a ver sus
calificaciones de entrevista y se le
miraba el colmillo largo y retorcido
chamaco así lo notaba se investigue el
misterio después encontré que sus papás
tenían empresa tiene mucho dinero y
pensé que a lo mejor no lee la
oportunidad niño de conocerlo
se mira muy muchacho es que lo vean si
me hago en muchachos también comprendí
que para el amor no hay edad
hay que apoyar a los hermanos no bien
tuve la oportunidad de ir este
paradisiaco lugar las islas fiji con la
suertuda de mi esposa la luna de miel
este hermoso lugar es parte de la
experiencia que calentamos un carro pues
ya saben volante del otro lado manejando
el otro lado muy padre y hasta costumbre
precondición la vuelta con equivoqué
muchas veces y da la vuelta y hay una
glorieta mirada y me topaba algunos ir a
todos nos enreden y con la sonrisa de
mediana 2 recuperos sabemos que eres
turista
seguro eres italiano por wappos la
sonrisa la sonrisa dice mucho como que
me decían hija que pare pero también a
bien manejando veíamos vemos de repente
un grupo de casas y dos pues ya no ya no
y otro grupo de casas y lo manejando nos
llamó la atención cuando regresamos le
preguntamos al mesero y nos dice es que
este país se fundó en villas ese grupo
de casas que tú veías son villas las
villas tiene un jefe que es un jefe
porque eso es para que de felipa para si
tienes una tradición delante interesante
y está basado no hay verso unos a otros
por ejemplo dice si yo necesito azúcar
voy con mi vecino le pido su camión de
azúcar a que pagara dijo oye hice un día
si tienes azúcar y le empieza el vecino
no le pidió si no tengo azúcar
yo sí sí sí pero pues él no sabe si
tienes tú le pides pero para qué le
pides que tengas más ciencia no es que
sí hasta que me pasó ya estás
corrompiendo el hombre ya para león
vamos a regresar en un año o dos y un
robadero que pasó aquí tu bien un
mexicano muy guapo y nos enseñó nos
enseñó a robar digo y van a decir eso no
pero sí que interesan también lo que me
interesa ver era la reacción del señor o
sea él no concebía siquiera lo que era
hacer trampa o sea no me dijo no es que
eso está mal y aquí me enseñaron de
entendemos ni siquiera lo concebía se
tenía bien arraigada la importancia
hacer lo correcto de ser honesto de
pedir solamente si él necesitaba algo
interesante no la historia este niño
también me encanta un niño de china que
le dijeron su salón quiere ser el
responsable de la seguridad del salón él
dijo sí a buenos en caso de una
evacuación tú tienes que ayudar a los
niños a seguir la ruta de emergencia a
la salida de las ocasiones y temáticas y
se lo compró tanto lo entendió también
que en el 2008 hubo un terremoto
tremendo en china su escuela se vino
abajo tanto los rescatistas entre los
escombros buscando y buscando y de
repente entre los escombros al este niño
se ven sus cicatrices en la foto
sangrado lastimado sal entre los
escombros lo ven y antes de que lo
empiecen a ayudar se vuelve a meter
entre los escombros
ahora gente estaba asombrada qué pasó y
al minuto sale pero sale con varios
niños atrás de él
eligieron y por qué te volviste meter
escriba responsable la seguridad cuando
yo encontré la salida mi responsabilidad
regresar enseñar los demás niños cómo
salir y se arriesgó se vuelve a meter
porque tenía bien claro que hacer lo
correcto era regresar por los demás
niños se está que tan importante es lo
que tenemos que aprender si no cuando
decimos a mi inglés enseñado mi
ingeniero no nos vamos a hacer lo
correcto hay que pasar a nutrirnos de un
pequeño y yo quisiera que es reflexión
reflexionemos más al respecto que
hablemos más de esto y estamos en el bar
están platicando he pensado que si
nuestra cultura si vamos al bautizo lo
que era el divorcio estemos platicando y
si cierto porque ingeniero no porque nos
haga cambiar eso yo creo que estamos en
el momento idóneo horita porque tenemos
a los milenios y después bien los
entendidos o la generación 7ma y son
jóvenes que tienen ganas de cambiar todo
lo quieren cambiar así es que es cambiar
algo único ahora le puedes cambiar eso y
si escuchamos muchas cosas del mineral
hizo esto que está aquí decimos eso ya
no escuchen hoy tu hijo que ya no
escucha están cerró y con el teléfono ya
no escucha hemos escuchado cosas como
éstas ya no decimos nuestros hijos
alguien dijo son tiranos responden a sus
padres son malos
alguien dijo no y este mundo ya llegó a
un punto crítico pues los hijos ya no
escuchan a su padre si hemos escuchado
cosas de ese tipo imagino los jóvenes
son ociosos ellos jamás serán como la
juventud de antes pues si tenemos
ponemos con otra juventud pero lo que me
pregunto es
ahorita hemos tenido problemas con
juventud cada generación me lo pregunto
porque mire lo primero dijo sócrates
cuatrocientos años antes de cristo lo
segundo se dijo por allá dos mil años
antes de cristo del río tercero hace
cuatro mil años y esto seguro que si nos
vamos a los cavernícolas también decían
a este chamaco bien escucha talibán
cerraron su cueva y en el muro social
ya están los chamacos hoy casi un
bendito vemos pintor preso decimos que
quiera decir esa manchita un lado será
un like
estas rayas azules pues un mensaje visto
para lo mismo de ese quién sabe qué
tantas cosas verán en estos muros
sociales en sus cuevas algo tenemos es
el problema pero es el momento ideal
porque decimos que no escuchen pero
estoy seguro que si escuchan bien el
sporting con historia un señor un alto
ejecutivo de la empresa y en eeuu en un
evento después de la cena un señor que
casi no habla de cosas personales de ir
muy muy frío y esta vez se sintió como
empezó a practicar me dijo mira mi hija
que es muy lineal y le salió buena para
nadar yo ni siquiera sé nadar empezó a
competir y competir y competir le ha ido
muy bien es y una vez me dijo papá viene
una competencia y es aquí en el
ciudadanía y realmente quiero ganar esta
competencia profe nerviosa porque viene
la niña de esa otra escuela por allá y
ya me ha ganado y siempre estamos
encerrados quiero ganar estoy estresada
bien entrenado muy duro dijo el papá
nada ya sabes la técnica ya las aves
junto con ella vamos a enfocar y demás
pero sabes que sabes quién va a ganar le
dijo la que realmente quiere ganar
porque todo está aquí que dijo aquí está
la diferencia de aquí va a salir la que
realmente quiera ganar esa es la que va
a ganar a mí caquis está aquí está la
clave se llegó el día la competencia
bien se me generan todas las gradas
llenas mucha gente
todos lados toda la emoción le toca
competir a ella se avientan a ver que lo
esperado
muy cerca de la otra niña cómica y al
final se adelanta poquito y gana a la
niña toda la gente para las gradas y
todo mundo emocional ovacionando
gritando niña se sale empieza a llorar
abraza a sus compañeros ahora su coach
voltea las gradas a la gente hoy tan
emocionada viendo las gradas viendo la
gente como podía pero ya realmente está
buscando su papá y de repente cuando
significa un señor con lágrimas dices es
mi papá lo único que hizo ya viéndolo
fue así
un gesto si tan sencillo me dice él en
ese momento me sentí grande sentí que
crecí sentí que me elevé y me sentí un
superhombre no sabe lo que sentí yo digo
eso tan grande que sintió él con un
pequeño detalle de ello porque yo de
disco tenías razón papá tenía razón todo
estaba aquí
gracias por lo que me dijiste pero
también le dijo escuche y no porque seas
un experto en natación porque no ver
esto escuche porque eres mi papá y
porque sabes cómo hablar si escuchamos
todo el mundo escuchas cosas que lo
intentemos y encontremos la manera de
hablar y estamos el momento idóneo para
cambiar estas cosas a otra cultura para
enriquecer nuestra cultura no esperemos
que venga un gobierno o una organización
niega grandes cambios grandes cosas no
nosotros podemos empezar en este momento
con esos pequeños detalles con estas
pequeñas cositas que generan grandes
cambios porque el secreto de los grandes
cambios está en esos pequeños detalles
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]